l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 585 de Monsieur François
Grosdidier à Monsieur le Ministre du
redressement productif vous avez la
parole chers collègues ma question
effectivement s'adresse à Monsieur
lemisement productif la restructuration
de la plateforme pétrochimique de Carlin
Saint-Avold a été un nouveau
bouleversement pour l'économie Moselle
la fermeture du vapo cracker est un
séisme de plus il frappe ce bassin
mouillé qui avait assuré une large
partie de sa reconversion par la
pétrochimie et cela arrive alors que
dans ce même département le bassin s'est
dérogique n'est pas compensé avec un
indéfinissable centre de recherche
publique de la fermeture des haut
fourneaux de Gandrange et que
l'agglomération médecine voit avec
éco-moove s'évaporer tout un pan de la
compensation des pertes d'emploi liées à
la restructuration de la défense
dans cette Moselle est qui va encore
plus mal que la Moselle ouest l'annonce
de Total est donc tragique j'ai noté les
engagements de ce groupe pour pérenniser
l'activité sur le site et la spécificité
de ce site est notamment les 160
millions d'euros d'investissement dans
de nouvelles lignes de production de
polymère de matériaux thermoplastiques
et de résine d'hydrocarbures et les 110
emplois
générés par ces investissements qui ont
été annoncés ne compensent cependant pas
les 210 emplois directement supprimés
par la fermeture du vapo cracker et
moins encore les beaucoup plus nombreux
suppressions d'emplois induits
aujourd'hui non encore évalué chez les
sous-traitants ce sont donc tous ces
emplois supprimés directs et indirects
qu'il faut considérer et qu'il faut
compenser par la création d'autres
emplois productifs en mosal-est le
groupe Total exprimait clairement sa
volonté de moderniser d'adapter une
petite pétrochimiques de Carlin comme je
l'ai dit mais comment les pouvoirs
publics étant et collectivités
territoriale ensemble et les partenaires
sociaux seront-ils associés au suivi des
investissements projetés qui engagent
l'avenir du pays naborien et de la
Moselle est enfin il y a d'autres
conséquences que celles sur l'emploi
direct et sur les sous-traitants il y a
celle sur l'approvisionnement propylène
et en éthylène décide pétrochimiques
notamment une hausse Arkema à saralbe il
faut obtenir des engagements et décider
les investissements pour sécuriser ses
approvisionnements tant sur le plan
économique que sur le plan physique et
garantir la sécurité des populations
concernées par les transports de matière
dangereuses à l'évidence cette situation
nouvelle résultante d'affermeture du
vapo cracker exige des investissements
urgents tant sur Carlin que sur sa ralbe
d'au moins 25 millions d'euros par site
croisant financement public et alors y
a-t-il des discussions très partites
entre total Arkema INEOS qui sont à la
fois en relation de clients fournisseurs
mais aussi en relation de concurrence
qu'elles sont aussi des discussions et
des engagements avec l'État qu'elle
engagement le gouvernement a-t-il reçu
d'appâts du groupe Total et quelles
contribution financières rapportera
l'état tant à la revitalisation du site
de Carla Saint-Avold qu'à la
sécurisation de l'approvisionnement des
sites de Sarralbe
madame le ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur je vous prie d'aborder
l'absence de mon collègue en nous
Montebourg qui est actuellement de
retour d'un déplacement aux États-Unis
après l'annonce par Total au mois de
septembre 2013 de la fermeture du vapo
cracker de Carlin à l'horizon 2015 le
Gouvernement a souhaité avoir toutes les
garanties du groupe Total concernant
l'avenir de sa plateforme pétrochimique
de Carlin pour Total la plateforme de
Carlin a vocation à devenir un centre
européen leader sur le marché des
résines hydrocarbures sièges européens
centre de recherche nouvelle unité de
production et transformation de l'unité
existante et renforcera son activité
polymère nouvelle unité de
polypropylène comparentes développant de
polyester et modernisation du
polyéthylène
dans le cadre de son projet total s'est
engagé à respecter l'ensemble de ses
engagements contractuels vis-à-vis de
ses clients et le gouvernement y sera
vigilant pour se faire total prendra en
charge les investissements nécessaires
pour consolider la logistique rail pour
le profilène et la logistique pas line
pour les tylène les clients seront
alimentés à partir d'autres sites
français de Total total est engagé à
conduire ce redéploiement industriel
sans aucun licenciement et s'engage
également accompagner ces entreprises
partenaires notamment en Lorraine qui
seront concernés par l'évolution du site
en mettant en place notamment un fond de
soutien en réponse à une demande de
l'État totale c'est également déclarée
favorable à l'élaboration d'une charte
de l'emploi local entre la CCPN Pôle
emploi et l'entreprise dans l'objectif
de favoriser l'emploi local et ainsi
confirmer son implication dans la vie
économique régionale total nous indiquer
qu'il incitera une la RGE participation
des entreprises locales dans les travaux
de démantèlement et de construction qui
auront lieu sur le site
qui s'appuie sur le professionnalisme
des salariés du site mais aussi sur la
position géographique de Carla proche de
marché européen en croissance en
investissant 160 millions d'euros d'ici
2016 dans de nouvelles activités le
projet permettra de restaurer la
compétitivité du site Laurent
aujourd'hui fragilisée par un vapo
cracker lourdement déficitaire merci
madame la ministre monsieur Grosdidier
souhaitez-vous répondre à madame la
ministre
madame la ministre j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour votre personne de
considération j'ai aussi beaucoup de
respect pour votre fonction mais doit
dire je suis choqué que le gouvernement
de la République puisse confier à la
Ministre chargée
des Français de l'étranger de répondre à
une question sur l'économie Moselle je
sais pas si c'est d'un désinvolture ou
de la légèreté mais vous direz quand
même monsieur Hérault et Montebourg que
vous avez excusé malgré tout la semaine
dernière
nous avons fêté commémoré le 95e
anniversaire du retour de la Moselle de
Alsace dans la République et je sais pas
si il est habituel que mise à faire
étrangères vous-même répondiez aux
questions de nos collègues d'outre-mer
les questions mais mais je trouve pour
ma part cela choquant je pense que dans
le pôle de Bercy et puis y avoir une
personne chargée de répondre à cette
question
sur le fond vous avez confirmé les les
engagements le connu de Total je
m'inquiète un peu malgré tout de n'avoir
eu ni chiffre ni délais dans votre
réponse ni d'avoir ressenti dire une
appréhension globale du problème des
sous-traitants je sais que Total va
gérer le problème de ces salariés c'est
que Total va souhaiter conserver ces
clients mais là encore j'aurais mes
connaître les clés de répartition entre
financement public et privé parce que il
nous est dit que les investissements
privés annoncés ne suffirait pas à
sécuriser les les investissements
nécessaires à la sécurisation des
approvisionnements donc je reste malgré
tout un peu sur ma faim merci chers
collègues je ne doute pas que Madame la
Ministre transmettra à son collègue vos
observations
très bien l'ordre du jour appelle